What's it like working with Mark Wahlberg in Boston?
Oh my gosh.
It's fantastic.
'Cause we're in all these little towns
Framingham, Wellesley.
Hmm mmm.
Concord.
(audience laughing)
You like that?
Dorchester.
And there was inevitably someone
in every town that Mark knew.
Someone yeah, hey Mark!
Mark!
(audience laughing)
It's me, Bleacher.
(audience, host laughing)
What?
And I'd be like Mark, there's some guy name Bleacher.
Yeah, that's his name.
He use to sleep in the bleachers.
Yeah, yeah.
(audience laughing)
Like literally Mark was like
sometimes hounded by people but.
Are these people you really knew from childhood?
Unfortunately, yes.
(audience, hosts laughing)
Yep and related to him.
They show up unannounced.
Uninvited all the time.
(audience laughing)
You owed them all money right?
Yeah or money or something.
There's always some sort of debt, some sort of issue.
You know, never a good thing.
It's me Squiggy!
(audience, host laughing)
I'm little T's brother!
You don't, I'm Squiggy!
Yeah.
That's fantastic.
There was always an explanation.
There's always yeah.
Have you noticed this in Boston,
they like to take you down a notch, too.
Oh absolutely.
Nobody more than my mother.
My own family.
Your mother does that to you?
What, you think you're a star?
You're nothing.
Yeah.
(audience, host laughing)
Oh absolutely.
(audience, hosts laughing)
And that's in front of my parish priest
whose about to baptize my kid.
You're nothing!
Really, at the baptism of your child?
Right there.
You think you're a star!
(audience, host laughing)
Exactly.
No I had the experience of gawking into Logan Airport
and I was headed to the back of the cab line
like everybody else.
Sure.
And I sat up there and before I could even get
to the back of the cab line, the guy was like,
yeah, back of the line for you TV star!
(audience laughing)
Welcome to Boston.
I was like I was headed that way!
He's like, yeah!
(audience laughing)